a week of political and economic tension
surrounding Greece starting on Monday
with the eurozone summit on the reform
package Athens presented for a third
bailout plenty of division from MEP ease
on the results our pain more suffering
alertly witnesses it's just
ideologically driven humiliation we hung
high on dirt billion oil overwrites the
fur gang hard to come by after for
Langley undone perform not English there
is a Greek cordis a that will go on for
many years to come
Thursday gave members of the Economic
Affairs Committee a chance to air their
views hours after the Greek parliament
adopted the first set of demanded
performs the new measures that were
proposed range stabilizing the economy
it's unfair meanwhile Rome burns Athens
to thousands of refugees continue to
arrive in each last month Member States
agreed to voluntarily relocate forty
thousand Parliament civil liberties
committee once more agreeing on first
aid a recommendation for a binding
emergency mechanism as a set of rules
that would take the refugees needs into
account this ahead of a more permanent
scheme for managing refugees in the
future when the Commission comes up with
a permanent relocation scheme which
should happen in the end of the year
then the number needs to be much more
substantial forty thousand can only be
the start in European Parliament
President Martin Short started a tour of
the Balkans on Monday first Albania
Serbia and Bosnia Herzegovina all three
plus other Former Yugoslav Republic's
and Kosovo are aiming for EU membership
after the wars and upheaval of the
mamaia so more toward a corporate zone
in the camp isn't a lagoon this openness
in Western Balkans six cinta by
convention in the ratio an important
being the end of the week of political
and economic tension surrounding Greece
starting on Monday with the eurozone
summit on the reform package Athens
presented for a third bailout plenty of
division from MEP ease on the results or
pain or suffering allows the middling
exits
it's just ideologically driven
humiliation we hum dry on dirt billion
oil ha polite stuff again - London will
go on many years to come
Thursday gave members of the Economic
Affairs Committee a chance to air their
views hours after the Greek parliament
adopted the first set of demanded
performs the new measures that were
proposed range stabilizing the economy
meanwhile Rome burns Athens to thousands
of refugees continue to arrive in each
last month Member States agreed to
voluntarily relocate 40,000 parliament
civil liberties committee once more
agreeing on Thursday a recommendation
for a binding emergency mechanism as a
set of rules that would take the
refugees needs into account this ahead
of a more permanent scheme for managing
refugees in the future
when the Commission comes up with a
permanent relocation scheme which would
happen in the end of the year then the
number needs to be much more substantial
40,000 can only be the start European
Parliament President Martin Schulz
started a tour of the Balkans on Monday
first Albania in Serbia and Bosnia
Herzegovina all three plus other Former
Yugoslav Republic's and Kosovo are
aiming for EU membership after the wars
and upheaval of the 1991 mayor so what
were the corporate zone in the camp ISM
tebron is enough in Western Balkans six
cyntha by pin mention indirectly owned
and in wouldn't be in a negative so cool
so after the end of the line nearly for
the passenger name record in which
people's flight data are retained to
help track criminals and terrorists the
potential erosion of privacy was the
issue holding this up for years but the
civil liberties committee struck a
balance it's hoped it'll be finalized by
the end of 2015
changed the original Commission report
quite a lot because many of the groups
felt that it didn't have really enough
safeguards in place for a start in terms
of the privacy of data which is very
important to us all at the moment the
end of the line nearly - for roaming
charges after the industry committee
approved a deal reached with Member
States the upshot the same cold text and
data charges anywhere in Europe by 2017
yippee
on Wednesday MEP s on the Environment
Committee called for tougher new
national ceilings on air pollutants
which are responsible for around 400,000
premature deaths in the EU each year the
aim is to cut emissions of pollutants
like sulfur dioxide and nitrogen oxides
by 70 percent by 2050